[Musique]
et
la cinquième édition de au bonheur des
enfants a débuté près de 150 agents du
département sont directement associés à
l'organisation de cet événement parmi
eux karine leveneur agents
administratifs depuis trois ans à la
direction des moyens généraux
c'est un effet un troisième année que
voir ce que ted événements concernant la
partie administrative
lyon joue en afrique
des forains ou son propre compte mais
les forains puis je ne peux pas un tel
nous nous ont fait entrer les
renseignements concernant chaque forain
[Musique]
bonjour oui
concernant votre candidature est la
bonne idée un travail qui lui a permis
de dépasser sa différence et d'être
totalement intégré c'est que je filtre
hepa nuit de mon travail j'aime
travailler avec mes directeurs ainsi
qu'avec mes collègues j'ai su trouver ma
place facilement et venir travailler
j'aime voix est un plaisir pour une
prise de contact qui continue sur le
terrain puisque au lendemain de
l'inauguration de la manifestation car
il va à la rencontre des faux gras cette
phase d hier soir la côte est pour lui w
tout le monde s'il était content
essentielle si je me fonde la
manifestation bouddha niveau
nous ne le dit pas durant toute la
manifestation bonheur des enfants karine
sera présente chaque jour dans le jardin
de l'état pour répondre aux demandes des
forains et veiller au bon déroulement de
l'événement
[Musique]